Estados Unidos acaba de salir de un ciclo
electoral y ya está embarcado en otro:
las elecciones del 5 de noviembre de 2024 ya
están en el radar. Y eso, eso significa una cosa:
las primarias de los partidos para escoger
a sus candidatos están a punto de caramelo.
Y, por ahora, el partido republicano parece
que tendrá las primarias más disputadas.
(Durante los últimos años, el
expresidente Trump además de
acumular una enorme colección de
acusaciones judiciales y derrotas
electorales, también ha dividido y
radicalizado al partido republicano.
Hoy es fácil encontrar a partidarios suyos que
niegan que Estados Unidos sea una democracia,
que cuestionan la legitimidad de los tribunales,
los fiscales y el propio sistema electoral.
Hablamos en muchos casos de auténticos forofos que
han encontrado en Trump a su particular mesías.)
Y por eso, cada vez son más los
republicanos que creen que ha
llegado la hora de pasar página,
apostar por un nuevo liderazgo y
volver a los principios y las posiciones
que hasta la llegada de Trump les definía.
Incluido el sentido de estado,
el compromiso con la verdad y,
sí, el respeto por el contrincante político.
[Guau, que lejos parece ese tiempo.]
Ahora bien, todavía no está claro que
lo vayan a conseguir porque Trump,
sí, Trump, se vuelve a presentar como candidato.
Y no solo eso. A pesar de sus escándalos sexuales,
como el de la antigua actriz porno Stormy Daniels,
del asalto al Capitolio y la aparición de
numerosos documentos clasificados en su casa,
Trump se ha vuelto a colocar en lo
más alto de la carrera republicana.
(“Nunca me marcharé”: Trump promete
permanecer en la carrera presidencial
de 2024 incluso si es condenado - The Guardian)
¿Podría Trump forzar a los republicanos a
tener un candidato a presidente procesado
por un delito federal o, incluso,
condenado y tal vez encarcelado?
Pues según muchos expertos en leyes
estadounidenses, por poder podría hacerlo.
Por ahora no hay ningún impedimento legal para
presentarse a las elecciones presidenciales,
incluso aunque terminase entre rejas. Es
más, ya hay dos precedentes de algo así:
En 1920 Eugene Debs, líder del Partido Socialista,
presentó su candidatura desde prisión. Y
en 1992 hizo lo propio Lyndon LaRouche,
un teórico de la conspiración que había
sido condenado por fraude en 1988.
Ahora bien, un momento, este vídeo no va del
expresidente Trump. No al menos directamente.
Por eso, tenemos que hacernos unas cuantas
preguntas: ¿Es Trump imparable? Lo veremos.
¿Está el Partido Republicano condenado a no
pasar página? Difícilmente, tarde o temprano
lo hará. ¿No hay acaso otras figuras capaces
de luchar por la candidatura republicana?
Pues sí, las hay. De hecho, son ya varios los
políticos que han anunciado su candidatura a
las primarias republicanas. Entre ellos
tenemos al senador por Carolina del Sur,
Tim Scott, al propio vicepresidente de
Trump, Mike Pence. A la ex-gobernadora
de Carolina del Sur y antigua embajadora ante
la ONU, Nikki [JEILI] Haley o al ex-gobernador
de Nueva Jersey y antiguo aliado de
Trump, Chris Christie, entre otros.
Pero si hay un candidato que se ha presentado
pisando fuerte, con fama, apoyos importantes
y mucho, muchísimo dinero, ese no es otro que
el actual gobernador de Florida, Ron DeSantis.
Todos habéis oído hablar de este
político que consiguió barrer en
las últimas elecciones en el estado de Florida.
Un hombre que ha conseguido transformar un
estado históricamente bisagra, es decir,
disputado a cara de perro por demócratas a
republicanos, a uno fuertemente republicano.
Por ejemplo, hace tan solo cinco años,
en 2018, DeSantis ganó las elecciones a
gobernador por apenas 32.500 votos, un
margen del 0,4 %. ¿Y en 2022? En 2022,
sin embargo, DeSantis ganó con un
margen de - atención - 19 puntos.
Ahora bien, ¿qué ha hecho este tipo
que parece tan serio para levantar
pasiones en el estado del sol? ¿Sería
capaz reproducir este increíble éxito
a nivel federal si finalmente fuese el
candidato republicano a la Casa Blanca?
Pues bien, en este vídeo, queridos amigos,
os vamos a contar todas las claves sobre este
peso pesado de la política estadounidense.
Os contaremos cuáles han sido sus principales
hitos en Florida, qué visión tiene para el
país y también os contaremos por qué
tiene serias papeletas para terminar
siendo un duro contrincante para los demócratas.
[En nuestra newsletter NotNews, por cierto, os
iremos compartiendo los datos y los hitos claves
de la campaña. Empezando por una radiografía de
los candidatos que os enviaremos en los próximos
días Un momento, ¿qué todavía no estás suscrito
a NotNews.com? ¿A qué estás esperando? Todavía
estamos empezando, pero ya somos miles de amigos
y os prometemos ir mejorando mes tras mes. Es 100%
gratuita y estamos preparando muchas sorpresas.
Y si ya estáis suscritos, o s gusta
lo que hacemos y queréis apoyarnos
para que sigamos mejorando, no dudéis en
echarle un vistazo a nuestra comunidad
de Patreon. Un millón de gracias
a todos los que nos acompañáis.]
Y ahora sí, arranquemos con Ron DeSantis,
¿La promesa estrella o estrellada del GOP?
Adelante.
T1 (EL ÉXITO DE RON)
Conservadurismo a la antigua usanza mezclado
con toques de tipo duro, algo de carisma,
un poco de populismo por aquí y por allá
y formas y discursos bastante polémicos.
Ese sería el mejunje que podría
describir a DeSantis en una sola frase,
pero, evidentemente no, no nos
vamos a quedar solamente en eso.
Este gobernador ha dado mucho de qué
hablar y el motivo lo tenemos en Florida,
el estado de moda del que es gobernador.
(En los últimos años, Florida está
viviendo un intenso despegue económico,
con tasas de crecimiento superiores a las
del resto del país y una tasa de desempleo
prácticamente en mínimos históricos del 2,5%.
Algo que, además está impulsando la competencia
de las empresas por buscar trabajadores. Lo
que está haciendo crecer los salarios en un
Estado con salarios tradicionalmente
bajos en el contexto norteamericano).
Con todos estos datos seguro que no os extrañará
saber que Florida fue en 2022 el Estado que más
población ganó de todo el país, con un
crecimiento anual de casi el 2%. Además,
buena parte de esta población no vino
del extranjero, sino de otros estados
como por ejemplo Nueva York o Illinois.
Dos estados que junto a California se
han convertido en 3 colosos, los 3 demócratas,
por cierto, que no paran de perder población.
El caso es que por todos estos motivos,
la principal carta de presentación de Ron
DeSantis d e cara a las primarias
republicanas es, precisamente,
presentarse con experiencia de gestión y
hechos, éxitos que hablen por él y no solo
palabras vacías. Y ojo que no solo hablamos
de estadísticas, también, como veremos,
de muchos cambios legislativos muy
importantes para los conservadores.
Pero, ahora bien, exactamente,
¿qué ha hecho Ron DeSantis?
Y lo que es todavía más importante,
¿realmente es oro todo lo que reluce?
Pues bien, ya os adelanto que en esta
historia hay para todos los gustos,
hay cal y arena a partes iguales.
Digamos que mientras que el fuerte desempeño
económico de Florida es algo innegable, la
trayectoria de este gobernador ahora precandidato
está repleta de políticas que a unos os gustarán y
a otros os horrorizarán. En cualquier caso,
palabra, que no os dejarán indiferentes.
Vamos con ellas.
T2 (EL HOMBRE DE HIERRO DEL PARAÍSO)
DeSantis es un político que, en materia social,
recuerda y mucho al republicanismo
conservador más tradicional.
Y sí, en Florida no ha escatimado en
esfuerzos para hacer virar las políticas,
las leyes y las regulaciones del estado
hacía posiciones más conservadoras.
O como le gusta decir a él, “anti-woke”, que
en español no tiene una traducción exacta,
pero que sería algo así como anti-progre.
Pues bien, DeSantis ha conseguido
convertirse en una de las figuras
más relevantes de la corriente
anti-woke en Estados Unidos.
(Por un lado, podríamos empezar
mencionando su impulso a una ley
que prohíbe que las universidades puedan emplear
dinero federal o estatal para desarrollar
actividades que promocionen la diversidad,
la igualdad y la inclusión.
DeSantis quiere sacar del
sistema educativo debates que considera
han sido impuestos por la izquierda.
Esta misma Ley también obliga a las
universidades a revisar sus planes
de estudio para que los temarios no
distorsionen eventos históricos ni
incluyan teorías críticas basadas en la
raza. Con esto se pretende, por ejemplo,
sacar de las aulas las teorías que defienden
que la población afroamericana sigue sufriendo
una situación de discriminación o racismo
institucionalizado. ¿Recordáis el BLM? Pues eso.)
Pero esto no es más que el principio.
Otra de las leyes más polémicas del
gobernador de Florida ha sido la Ley de
Derechos de los Padres en la Educación,
más conocida popularmente como Ley “No digas gay”.
Esta Ley básicamente lo que hace es prohibir,
o mejor dicho, retrasar, la educación sexual,
incluido todo aquello que tenga que ver con la
diversidad sexual, en las escuelas públicas.
En un principio la ley prohibía este tipo de
formación hasta que los estudiantes tuvieran
entre 8 y 9 años de edad, pero se acaba
de ampliar hasta que tengan 13 y 14 años.
Por supuesto, para sus detractores esta Ley sirve
para discriminar a los estudiantes y las familias
LGTB, y también para prohibir libros o películas
en los colegios que aborden estas temáticas.
Sin embargo, para sus defensores esta
Ley tan solo hace que sean los padres
los que elijan el momento y la forma en
la que educan a sus hijos en esta materia,
en lugar de hacerlo el estado. Al menos
hasta que tengan una edad determinada.
Sin duda esta ha sido una de las
leyes más polémicas del gobierno
de DeSantis en Florida. Una Ley que le
ha costado un enfrentamiento salvaje,
a cara perro, con la mayor
empresa del estado: Disney.
(Tras las protestas, el CEO de Disney habla en
contra de la ley “No Digas Gay” de Florida - NPR)
Ahora bien, ¿por qué es esto
tan importante? Pues bien,
pensadlo un momento, ¿qué hay en la ciudad
de Orlando que le gustaría visitar a todos
los niños del mundo? ¡Exacto! el
complejo temático Disney World.
Pues bien, el caso es que precisamente por tener
tanta presencia en este estado, Disney empezó a
recibir fuertes presiones por parte de activistas
para que se posicionaran en contra de esta Ley.
Y bueno, cuando finalmente lo
hicieron… Digamos que DeSantis
perdió los papeles y empezó a comportarse
prácticamente como un caudillo bananero.
[Sí, este es quizás uno de sus
mayores borrones en el historial.
¿Arremeter contra la mayor empresa
del estado y amenazarla con cambios
y castigos legales por ejercer su derecho
a expresarse como les dé la gana? No sé,
no suena muy bien. Mal ahí, gobernador.]
(El gobernador de Florida, Ron DeSantis,
firma una ley para poner el distrito de
Disney bajo el control estatal - CBS News)
En este vídeo no vamos a entrar en
esto de los distritos gestionados
por empresas… De eso hablaremos en otra ocasión.
Pero lo que sí creo que tenemos que
tener en cuenta es que un político
no debería usar su poder para castigar
política y fiscalmente a empresas que se
expresen en su contra. El estado que
gobiernan no es su cortijo personal.
Pero al señor DeSantis le dio un poco
igual. De hecho, se suele comparar con
Teddy Roosevelt a la hora de lanzar su
particular cruzada contra las grandes
corporaciones. Porque sí, Ron DeSantis tiene
a las grandes corporaciones en su diana.
Ahora bien, si creéis que eso es todo,
estáis muy equivocados. DeSantis ha dado
mucho más de sí en sus más de cuatro
años como gobernador de Florida.
(Este gobernador también ha
impulsado leyes para prohibir
que las agencias estatales tengan en
cuenta los criterios ESG, esto es,
los criterios ambientales, sociales y
de gobernanza, a la hora de invertir.
Recientemente también ha prohibido el aborto
a partir de las seis semanas de embarazo,
en lugar de las 15 semanas que el propio
DeSantis estableció en 2022. Lo que para
los críticos equivale a prohibir una gran parte
de los abortos porque un tercio de las mujeres
se enteran de que están embarazadas después de las
seis semanas, y un 20% lo hace incluso más tarde.)
Ya veis que todo tiene un patrón común.
DeSantis va de frente y a toda velocidad
contra consignas que han dominado durante los
últimos años el discurso político. A su lado,
Trump es prácticamente un
aprendiz. Entre otras cosas,
por una cuestión de convicción. Ron DeSantis
cree realmente en todos estos cambios.
Y siguiendo esta particular agenda
conservadora ‘made in America’,
¿Qué nos falta? Exacto… Otra de las
medidas relevantes de DeSantis en
Florida ha sido flexibilizar mucho
el uso y porte de armas de fuego.
Concretamente, ha promovido una Ley
que permite a cualquier persona en
Florida poseer armas y llevarlas ocultas por la
calle, sin necesidad de tener ninguna licencia,
ni pruebas de entrenamiento, ni
comprobación de antecedentes,
nada de nada. Para DeSantis está claro:
portar armas es un derecho constitucional.
¡Ah, sí! También y eesta es otra de las
medidas polémicas del gobernador de Florida,
ha facilitado la pena de muerte,
eliminando la unanimidad de los 12
miembros del jurado que hasta ahora la ley
exigida por una supermayoría de 8 frente a 4.
¡Menuda agenda! Y todavía no hemos
llegado al tema de la inmigración.
DeSantis se ha convertido en una de las
figuras políticas más duras de Estados
Unidos con la inmigración ilegal.
Podemos decir que en Florida su
gobierno le ha declarado la guerra
a los inmigrantes indocumentados.
Y ojo porque esto es importante saberlo:
en Estados Unidos un inmigrante ilegal a
día de hoy en la práctica puede trabajar,
puede tener carnet de conducir e incluso puede
comprarse una casa o escolarizar a sus hijos.
En este sentido, es un país mucho
menos estricto que por ejemplo la
norma habitual en Europa o muchos países
asiáticos. Siempre que vayas a trabajar
y cumplas las normas y las leyes a
rajatabla, digamos que es un país
en el que se hace mucho la vista gorda
con eso de tener o no documentación.
Ahora bien, parece que a DeSantis no
le hace demasiada gracia este sistema
y por eso le ha declarado la guerra en Florida.
(El gobernador del estado del sol ha tomado toda
una serie de medidas como por ejemplo tipificar
como delito grave de tercer grado utilizar
un carnet falso para conseguir un empleo.
También ha prohibido que los
inmigrantes ilegales puedan conducir,
incluso en los casos en los que porten un
carnet de otro estado que no sea Florida.
Y no solo eso, los empleadores privados
con 25 o más trabajadores tendrán que
usar un sistema de verificación electrónica
de forma obligatoria para confirmar que los
trabajadores están legalmente en Florida. Y,
además, obligará a los hospitales que estén
adscritos al programa Medicaid a preguntar
por el estatus legal de los pacientes. Todas
estas son medidas diseñadas para facilitar la
identificación de los inmigrantes ilegales)
¿Sorprendidos? Amigos este tipo deja a Trump casi
como un progre pro-inmigración
a su lado. Pero es que es más,
todas estas medidas han ido acompañadas de
todo un show mediático bastante cuestionable.
¿Cuál? Pues… Fijaos.
(El floridano DeSantis manda a
decenas de "inmigrantes ilegales" a
Martha's Vineyard, intensificando la táctica
contra los "destinos santuario" - CBS News)
Ahora bien, ¿qué es eso de los destinos
“santuario” y por qué dedicar expresamente
12 millones de dólares a mandar a
decenas de inmigrantes a una isla
del estado de Nueva York, situada a
más de 1.600 kilómetros de Florida?
Pues bien, se trata ni más ni menos que de
una campaña de marketing político a nivel
nacional. Y la elección del destino
no es ni mucho menos accidental.
(Y es que, veréis, según las
leyes del estado de Nueva York,
las autoridades tienen que hacerse
cargo inicialmente de los inmigrantes
ilegales que llegan al estado, por
ejemplo, otorgándoles alojamiento.
Sin embargo, últimamente este sistema ha
colapsado debido a las llegadas masivas,
lo que ha hecho que muchos inmigrantes
tengan que ser alojados en hoteles,
algo que ha disparado el gasto del estado
y de la propia ciudad de Nueva York.)
Pues bien, la medida de DeSantis parece querer
atacar la línea de flotación de los estados y
ciudades santuario, esto es, territorios que
limitan su cooperación con el gobierno federal
en cuestiones de control migratorio, y que él
considera que promueven el efecto llamada de
inmigrantes ilegales. Inmigrantes que según
DeSantis en muchos casos entran por Florida.
Ahora bien, ¿por qué Martha’s Vineyard
Pues porque esta isla de Nueva York es el
destino favorito de vacaciones y segundas
residencias de un montón de millonarios
y políticos afines al Partido Demócrata.
Hasta el ex-presidente Barack Obama tiene una
casa de más de 12 millones de dólares allí.
Es decir que lo que DeSantis buscaba era hacer
que esas élites demócratas vivieran el drama de
la inmigración ilegal en su propio cortijo
vacacional. Eso al menos lo que su equipo
ha dicho para justificar semejante campaña… Que
si lo pensais bien y estéis o no de acuerdo con
ser más o menos estricto con la inmigración, no
hace sino tratar a las personas como ganado… Y
pagarse una campaña de publicidad nacional
a cargo de los contribuyentes de Florida…
Ahora bien, puede que llegados a este punto y
ahora que os hemos contado sus principales “hitos”
como gobernador, seguramente tengáis más o menos
claro el tipo de político, el perfil con el que
nos encontramos pero… ¿Qué hay de sus propuestas
para el conjunto del país? ¿Qué haría si fuera
presidente y qué posiciones tendría sobre los
asuntos más importantes a nivel internacional?
Pues bien, descubrámoslo.
T3 (MAKE AMERICA… FLORIDA)
Amigos de VisualPolitik, como seguramente ya os
habréis imaginado por el título de este bloque,
la agenda política de Ron DeSantis para Estados
Unidos se basa en una cosa: hacer América a imagen
y semejanza de su Florida. La Florida que él ha
estado cambiando durante los últimos cuatro años.
Por tanto, las líneas principales de la
política de DeSantis podrían pasar por
extender al conjunto del país todas o la mayoría
de las leyes que os hemos contado hace un momento.
Y eso incluye el extender y
facilitar la pena de muerte,
restringir la educación sexual hasta bien
entrada la adolescencia, la guerra frontal
contra la inmigración ilegal o la lucha contra
las grandes empresas que no le bailen el agua.
Ahora bien, la política a nivel federal es
distinta que la estatal en muchas cosas,
por ejemplo porque desde la Casa Blanca DeSantis
tendría que marcar una agenda internacional.
Y aquí, aquí es donde nos asaltan nuevas
dudas… ¿De qué forma DeSantis ve el
mundo? ¿Qué se puede esperar de sus
posicionamientos internacionales?
Pues bien, para saberlo lo primero que
debemos hacer es mirar a Ucrania. En el
Partido Republicano la división
actual es tan grande que hay un
sector mayoritario que es fuertemente
pro-Ucrania y OTANista y a la vez otro
sector fuertemente prorruso que exige el
fin de la ayuda estadounidense a Kyiv.
Y en medio… bueno, quizás en un término medio
es donde se encuentra actualmente DeSantis.
(En 2015, cuando era congresista y justo
después de la ocupación rusa de Crimea,
DeSantis fue uno de los grandes impulsores
de la ayuda militar americana a Ucrania.
Ahora, en cambio, su posición ha cambiado
y pasa porque que esta ayuda “no es vital”
para los intereses nacionales de Estados
Unidos. Según él, Estados Unidos tiene que
focalizarse en los problemas internos, como la
epidemia de opioides o la crisis migratoria.
La cuestión es que esos problemas ya existían
en 2015. Es decir, que DeSantis ha cambiado de
discurso en un tema tan importante simplemente
porque quiere captar los votos trumpistas. Algo
por lo que también ha puesto en duda la
imparcialidad y el objetivo político de
los juicios contra Donald Trump.)
Pero volvamos al tema exterior.
No ayudar a los aliados en temas “vitales” haría
que el país se mostrase como un socio poco fiable.
Y sí, esto podría volver a dar alas a los
regímenes totalitarios para actuar con impunidad.
[Todos recordamos cómo la inacción
y la ambigüedad de Trump terminó con
China cargándose ilegalmente el estatus
político especial que tenía Hong Kong…]
Sin embargo, no tan rápido porque la
agenda internacional de DeSantis puede
tener muchas más contradicciones que certidumbres.
Por ejemplo, si no hablamos de Ucrania, pero
hablamos de Taiwán, DeSantis dice que es un país
de interés crítico para Estados Unidos, y se ha
posicionado a favor de seguir supliéndoles armas.
Además, también, como gobernador,
ha sido muy beligerante con China,
llegando a prohibir a casi todos los ciudadanos
chinos invertir en inmuebles en Florida.
(Y no solo eso, también es un
fuerte defensor de Israel y de
la asistencia americana al país hebreo;
suscribe los Acuerdos de Abraham y por
supuesto defiende que la embajada
estadounidense esté en Jerusalén.
En el terreno latinoamericano, DeSantis se
opone a relajar las sanciones contra Cuba y
es muy crítico con el régimen de Maduro. Claro
que cuando se trata de ayudar a los inmigrantes
la cosa cambia. Porque muchos de los inmigrantes
que DeSantis ha expulsado en aviones de Florida y
los ha enviado a otros estados, eran precisamente
gente que huía del régimen chavista de Venezuela.)
En fin, ¿sabéis esto de no
predicar con el ejemplo? Pues eso.
DeSantis en resumidas cuentas es un político
que, como os decíamos al principio del vídeo,
mezcla conservadurismo en estado puro, mano dura,
carisma, algo de populismo y un extraño placer
por actuar sin importarle demasiado el qué dirán.
Claro que su mensaje nos alerta de que es un
político capaz de dejar vendido a un país como
Ucrania frente a Putin, quizás solo por una
mera cuestión electoral de cara a llegar a
2024 llevándole la contraria al actual inquilino
de la Casa Blanca y de paso regarle las orejas
al electorado trumpista - recordemos que
Trump siempre ha mantenido que todo esto
de la invasión de Ucrania lo arreglaba con
una llamada en cosa de 24 horas. ¡Qué miedo!
En definitiva, hablamos de un perfil lleno de
contrastes, contradicciones y guiños a sectores
radicales del GOP que ha hecho que muchos le vean
como una especie de “Trump con buenos modales”.
Aunque honestamente si sois conservadores, creo
que este candidato os gustará mucho más que Trump.
Ahora bien, llegados a este punto las
preguntas son para vosotros. ¿Qué pensáis
del perfil político de DeSantis? ¿Pensáis
que logrará su aparente objetivo de aunar
el apoyo del Partido Republicano más
tradicional y el de los trumpistas?
¿Logrará vencer a su antaño amigo y hoy
no tan amigo Trump en las primarias?
Pues bien, déjanos tus opiniones aquí abajo, en
los comentarios. Y recuerda, si te ha gustado
este vídeo no olvides darle like y suscribirte a
nuestro canal para no perderte ninguna novedad.
Ah, y también puedes suscribirte
a nuestro Patreon para recibir
contenidos y regalos exclusivos.
Tenéis el enlace en la descripción.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar
ahí. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.